A lot of the points that were really densely articulated in the preface, to me, they started
to feel like thesis statements here.
So it's like, he's sort of summarizing, but also articulating with a new, a kind of new
level of clarity for me, at least some of that stuff.
Yeah.
Well, the first couple of paragraphs just reads to a certain degree, like a bit of Latour
where it's like, Hey, guess what?
The laboratory, the instruments, the medium, whatever it is, you know, it's not uninvolved.
It is co-producing of the thing, which is the, like, for me, it's the first time that
I really understood why it's the phenomenology and not just spirit, right?
Because it's, you know, by actually taking the instrument or medium of cognition seriously,
then, you know, the, like, spirit is co-produced as a phenomenology, right?
And so just the way that he deals with the subject object problem in the first couple of pages
here is, I thought it was, it was, like, refreshing.
Right.
Yeah.
So, yeah, it echoes Latour, and then I've brought up Niels Bohr a few times, like, the
observer effect, the observer principle.
I think that's, like, almost word for word, you know, said in this first page, basically,
of the intro.
So, yeah.
The only interesting thought that struck me throughout this, or the only thought that I
was like, Hey, this might be something worth sharing with these guys.
You know, usually I feel like there's three or four things, and I'm like, Hey, there's
a, but this is the only one.
And it wasn't anything specific that he said.
It was just a kind of realization.
So we've talked about Hegel's sort of teleological and the problems with the particular teleology.
But the thing that kind of struck me here is that one of the problems that I hadn't maybe
clearly articulated to myself is it's not, the problem is not just the particular teleology
that he sees playing out.
It's that there's a teleology, that there is a direction towards which knowledge is
necessarily going, right?
Again, whatever that place might be, absolute spirit and whatever, whatever, that's a kind
of separate, I just didn't think of them as, it's kind of a separate question from the
fact that there is a perception that this is just where it's going, and it has to go.
So the existence of a teleology is, I think, also really apparent here, right?
Like, insofar as appearance and essence have to get wedded.
You know, there are a couple of different phrasings of it, but that's what, you know, it has
to go to a point.
It can't just be like an action in the world.
It has to be an action directed towards something.
Well, I mean, I was reading the, because this often strikes me as being quite Aristotelian,
and I was, I can't remember if I said this the last time, but I was reading the beginning
of the Nicomachean Ethics and, you know, in, you know, straight up the gut Aristotelian
fashion, he's like, he's articulating, you know, any act, any good in terms of, you know,
like you, you, the, the, the definition of any act is run through its particular goal,
its particular end, right?
So it doesn't, so it's not just that, you know, some act has some end or some good has
Some end, but it's that all, like, acts in and of themselves are, are only understandable
in virtue of their ends.
Right.
That's good.
The Aristotelian connection is good.
Yeah.
And, and, and, you know, um, he has some Aristotelian language in here and I think it's just very
hard to, that's a, that's a pretty common sensical way of thinking about things.
You know, it's, it's a, it's a means to an end.
Right.
It does feel like there are a couple versions of the goal for consciousness, uh, for Hegel here.
Like there's the goal for consciousness, which can sometimes get in the way of the larger
goal, which is sort of Hegel's goal, which is self-consciousness or achieving absolute
knowledge.
The, the kind of like vulgar or primary or immediate goals of consciousness actually like, uh, inhibit
the, the larger path, it seems like to absolute spirit.
Um, yeah.
And that, and I agree with you.
Like that's, that's one of the things that I think is, is interesting.
To me is that it both inhibits it and is a necessarily, necessarily relay to, to some
future point.
Um, so, so that's like, everything is that everything is like, well, it, it risks, I mean,
edification is his word for like, you know, the place where you stop.
It's like, well, everything risks edification.
Um, but it also is a moment in its own, you know, becoming unedified.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, looking at it from, um, you know, embedded in here, it's not overly explicit, but, um,
there's an embedded faculty psychology here where, you know, the, the distinct faculties
of the understanding and reason, you know, we tend to conflate those things, but for him
they're, they're quite different.
And, you know, you could trace this in, in Kant and, um, and others and, you know, there's
a, but there's an interesting dialectical tension between the understanding, which schematizes
and makes edifying, you know, surfaces to, to sort of stand on, right.
This is that it works propositionally, but then the reason is the thing that is constantly
unsettling those things that are taking, though, that are, that are probing those boundaries and
then taking them beyond themselves.
Well, I even feel, I even feel like there's a distinction between what sometimes is called
dialectical reason, which is the highest form of that and, and, and reason, right.
Like that, that I, I mean, I agree with you cause I've, I've, there's a passage of like
reason is required to move past understanding, right.
Um, so that, yeah, and you're right.
Understanding is, and we talked about that a little bit last time.
There's that one passage where it's like understanding is clearly a kind of bad guy here.
You know, it's, it's a problem, uh, and reason is the solution.
But I think also reason isn't the final solution.
I mean, I don't mean that in the, but I mean, reason itself has to become dialecticized.
It has to be, it can't simply be the application of, you know, that kind of Kantian, uh, uh, notion
of a faculty, it actually has to move beyond itself too.
So reason can calcify too, unless it is, unless you have that sort of the dialectical movement
in it.
But that brings things back a bit full circle a bit, because at the end of the preface in
66, um, he, he sort of brings up a problem of the dialectical as like, you know, the, the
two oppositionary positions, oppositional positions as sometimes mimicking too much, like what the
understanding does.
I mean, just to read that quickly, this is 66, the right at the very beginning here, we should
bear in mind that the dialectical movement likewise has propositions for its parts or elements.
The difficulty just indicated seems therefore to recur perpetually and to be inherent in the
very nature of philosophical exposition, right?
So like, even like that, you know, not even dialectical reason is able to sort of tap into
some kind of full movement.
It is itself constantly risking, um, uh, calcification in so far as you know, it is trying to, even though
it was trying to spur the movement of proper of, of propositions by forcing them to go beyond
themselves, you know, that even to say like, here are the parts of the pro of, of the dialectical
movement is to make dialectical movement too clunky.
Mm-hmm and the, I mean this, when you actually step towards reason or, uh, absolute knowing there's
the sense that there's danger in that, that step or in that progress.
So it's almost like the understanding is reacting against, uh, the, the progress of absolute spirit
and can kind of like retract from that.
And like, so there's, that's the feeling of dread, right?
That's the dread of one's foundations being moved beyond themselves, which is, he describes
as death, right?
Exactly.
This, and this uprooting entails its death in 80 there.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And there's, there's also a sense to me that this, the movement is way more arbitrary than,
than we normally think of in terms of the telos.
Like there's one portion, I mean, maybe I could pull it up, uh, in the intro where he says that
basically, the, the step towards reason happens on the back of consciousness so that we're not
even, you don't even know when you actually reach true dialectical knowledge.
And because of that, that's where the tendency to fold back into the understanding comes in.
So like, there's a sense that even for Hegel, there's no, like he, he didn't control his
own access to absolute knowing.
But that doesn't make it any more or less teleological.
That makes it less, um, like it, it, it shifts the agency.
And I think it makes us, we've been talking about a little bit, um, like, uh, a little
bit less humanist where it's not the subject, the human mobilizing reason as, I mean, this
is where the faculty of, you know, reason is a little bit less just simply under the control
of the human subject, but it's sort of just like an active engine that, you know, runs,
as we said last time, as in virtue of its being connected to a community of minds that
is, you know, the, the, the, the subject, the conscious subject is sort of, yeah, as you
say, like an after effect of all of this.
It's not a, it's not a humanist telos, right?
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's, it's much less motivated in the sense that we're like, we're not controlling
it.
I kept coming back to Bacon because with his Novum, Novum Organum, like the whole, well,
one of the goals of that project was to plant the seeds for a kind of purified technical scientific
knowledge of the world.
And it seems like Hegel here is like arguing almost explicitly against that, that notion of
progress.
Just in terms of a disposition though, like, I mean, it just occurs to me is like the extent
to which, yes, he says the propositions are a moment, but only a moment.
But at the same time, um, there's an investment in those points as points, even though they
can't simply be, they can't just be points.
In other words, I guess sort of what I'm thinking here is the logic of opposition just seems too
crude to me, right?
Like why, why not, here's a different kind of claim that one could make is say like, there
are no propositions, right?
Like those things that you thought were points just weren't ever points, right?
Like, and it's, it's a, uh, you know, a false conception of them to think that they're, they
are necessary moments in a progression because they're not moments in a progression.
Well, I think he, he does say that in, I mean, I, he's in, in his attempt to constantly under,
um, undermine the value of the proposition as something that is impossible.
He's, he's sort of like, look, propositions are impossible.
Also, it's the only movement possible for a dialectical philosophy.
And, but that's what I'm saying, but that, that framing of it, I'm saying it feels just
too coarse, like too, it's like, why not, why not just say, uh, propositions are impossible
and we've never had any.
Well, like, think about, you know, think about the two sides of the, I mean, to, to turn
to Deleuze, which is where I think you're, you're nudging it.
Yeah.
Think about the two sides of the flat playing of imminence.
And like, what you're suggesting is like, look, from the molecular side, there is no
such thing as propositions and there never has been, but from the, the molar side of things
is there are absolutely propositions and they're operative all the time.
Right.
And, and, you know, and those aren't incompatible claims.
They're not.
I agree.
That's why I said it's.
That's why I said it's, it's a, it's a style claim.
I mean, they're not logically incompatible, but they're stylistically incompatible.
Right.
It's a difference in emphasis too, because I don't think Deleuze would say that propositions
don't exist, but he would certainly go after the primary sort of granular movement of thinking
rather than the upper level, like calcified argumentative form.
Like, so, I mean, I think the Deleuzean or Nietzschean option is there.
I think it's just Hegel seems to be more intent on working with the stuff that we have as
as opposed to searching, as opposed to searching for something, I don't know, like completely
different.
You know what I mean?
Well, and also, in all fairness, like for early 19th century, this is fucking radical.
I mean, you know, when you historicize it that way, it's fucking genius.
Like, I'm not, and I don't mean to diminish that, but at the same time, I don't really
care about that.
Like, that historical value is irrelevant to me.
I just think like, well, today this just feels, you know, like the more provocative claim
would be there are no propositions.
And by the way, that's not, I mean, that claim is a precise claim, which is to say that propositions
don't have being.
They don't possess, they're not, they don't have is the quality of being, which could imply
any number of things, not the least of which would be they're always becoming, which would
be saying therefore the same thing, right?
But to say there are no, there are no propositions.
If you, you know, do a little bit of work on that proposition, there are no propositions.
That's, it's like the, you know, there aren't no truth claim, you know, like you, but you
can do the moves and, and it's just going to lead you in a really, even though conceptual,
I get that they are, you know, it's the same kind of, same kind of work, but one is being
handled very, very differently.
Again, maybe just stylistically, tonally or whatever.
Right.
Well, I wonder if Hegel's certain commitment to faculty psychology is sort of what's driving
that stylistic difference.
Whereas Deleuze sees faculties on the, along that same playing with it, there are no such
thing as faculties.
Faculties are getting made all the time and there are as many faculties as there are sets
of relations, right?
Whereas...
So there are no such thing as faculties with an emphasis on the word being, yeah.
Right, right, right.
But, I mean, for like, for the incredible amount of interrogation of the sort of assumptions
that go into things like instrument, medium, and even the anxiety that sort of like, he
introduces this really sophisticated anxiety about the instrument or medium affecting the...
Oh, no, yeah.
I mean, this is, I mean, think about the, think about the, what is the term that Harmon uses
that's, I can't remember what it is, but it's about like, you know, this question of how
do you comment, given that everything is only available for consciousness, right?
Like, how do you ever comment on anything?
I can't remember, they have a term for this, those guys, like Levy, Brian, you know, those
guys, and I can't remember what that term is, but it's very clearly the problem that he's
directly writing about here in the introduction, where he's like, how do you deal with them?
But Hegel's a step ahead of them.
Well, yeah, Hegel's...
Yeah.
And I don't mean historically.
I think conceptually, he's a step ahead of that, because like, he both anticipates that
fear, and then he undoes it at the same time, which is why he turns to the phenomenology
itself, which is to say, like, look, even the worry of the instrument or the medium getting
in the way is assuming, like, that fear is itself premised on a bunch of assumptions.
This is on the second page of the introduction.
That, like, it presumes a subject-object binaries, like, oh, I mean, to make that Kantian move,
here I am, you know, and I don't have access to my object of study, and, you know, there's
this sort of obscuring relationship, and, you know, he turns to make them much more imminent
and maybe even Nechein response to say that, like, look, this thing only exists in virtue
of its interaction with me, right?
And so I'm not getting at the thing itself, but I am producing a, like, the reactivity
here is every bit as real as it would be between other things, right?
So, like, even that fear is...
The line in 74, this is where he's talking about fear of falling into error, and the line
is, to be specific, it takes for granted certain ideas about cognition as an instrument
and as a medium, and assumes that there's a difference between ourselves and this cognition.
Yeah.
I mean, there it is.
I mean, T1, going above all, it presupposes that the absolute stands on the one side and
cognition on the other, independent and separated from it, and yet is something real.
Or, in other words, it presupposes that cognition, which, since it is excluded from the absolute,
is surely outside of the truth as well, is nevertheless true, and an assumption whereby what calls itself
fear of error reveals itself rather as fear of the truth.
Fear of the truth.
Right.
He does have a sense of humor.
That's funny.
I like this term.
That is funny.
I'm going to give you that one.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I like it.
But, um, uh, shit, what were we just talking about before we turned, I turned us here?
I don't know.
But, I mean, this is also, this is where the explicit step beyond Kant is kind of laid out on 74.
I mean, to say that the fear of erring is already the error itself, I mean, that's, that's turning
the capacity to err, or the inconsistency between subject and object, as the positive feature
of reality, as opposed to bracketing it as, like, the numeral reality that we can never access.
That inconsistency or crack in the kind of subjective edifice, how we interface with the world, that's
the thing in itself for Hegel, right?
Yeah.
So, like, again, it's not Deleuze.
So, there's a difference there.
I mean, if we want to go back to that, the tension between those kinds of thinking, it's
like, he still needs failure here, and lack, and inconsistency, whereas for someone like
Deleuze, you, I mean, he would basically ask the question, why do we need those terms?
If it's, if that's the positive feature of reality, then it's not a, it's not necessarily
a failure.
I think that, I mean, not to, I don't know, but the, the thing is, Hegel is so insistently
a phenomenologist, whereas Deleuze and Nietzsche, to an extent, are, I mean, what do you want
to call them vitalists?
They're more, yeah, they're more concerned with the movement of life, as opposed to just
strictly, you know, cognition, but, I don't know, it's still a problem that I've been
trying to work through, like, why, why does he need, because I'm still kind of on board
with this, at least for the mechanism of the subject, cognition, conceptuality, he kind
of, he needs failure and lack, you know, for it to work.
In this system.
But, we don't, I don't know.
That's as simple as, I mean, that's the restatement of the problem, I mean, you know, we've been
talking about this since the very, very, you know, beginning, is that if it's like, you
know, if it's perpetual, inevitable failure, then how is it failure?
Right.
Failure in relationship to what?
In relation to a projected, totalized unity, whether it's the real in Lacan, or, you know,
whatever term, you know, spirit here, or whatever.
Right.
Where in the text are you seeing those more explicit articulations of failure and lack
as a need?
Well, I guess they're not explicit really here, but the notion of fear, I mean, it's like fearing
the truth and then kind of trying to surpass that fear.
But that's what he's criticizing, right?
Like, he sets up this, he sets up like the sophisticated, a pretty sophisticated analysis,
and he's like, but people that fear this are mistaken.
Right.
Like, you know, yeah.
Yeah, no, I mean, it just, like, I don't know.
I don't know exactly how to articulate it right now, but there has to be a lack in the kind
of conceptual edifice for, like, as the motor.
So you have to be lacking, you have to be lacking total consistency or correspondence between
subject and object.
There's not, there's not, like, once he kind of implodes the system, it's still not flat
for Hegel.
There's still differences between subject and object, but those differences are internal
to the mechanism of the concept or of cognition.
So what's inconsistent is our relation to our own, like, faculty of cognition.
So that, it can never be fully consistent with itself or with the world.
You know what I mean?
Well, that, that, I think, there I follow you.
But that doesn't seem to be a subject-object distinction so much as it is a...
Subject-subject.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, fuck.
Well, that's not good.
Oh, we lost John.
Oh, no.
I thought he was too patiently listening.
Yeah, yeah.
I knew he was going to insert himself there, but he didn't.
Dread, it was interesting there as well, is that, you know, when you're talking about
the fear of, um, of how our cognition works as an instrument or medium, that was very different
than the dread that is produced by understanding, right?
That, that actually, I mean, this, this is, gets back to what you were talking about, about
how, like, reason really isn't ours to control.
In fact, reason is an agent of terror in, in, in our own lives is that, you know, understanding
provides a certain level of, of comfort and, and it is an inertia, um, um, you know, producing
instrument that stabilizes the world around us.
And it's reason's constant probing of those boundaries that inserts a sense of dread because
that stability is getting constantly undone, right?
Right.
Yeah.
The, the understanding kind of tames that dread, but it's actually the dread and despair that
Hegel wants us to pass through.
You know, it's like, you have to, it almost, it's kind of reminds me of like Nietzsche's
notion of like courage or like, the, to have the bravery to step into the, the kind of position
of the overman or of the eternal return.
'Cause there's a lot of anxiety that's traditionally produced with that kind, like if you're really
thinking that irreducible culpability of subject and object and vice versa, there's no, like,
there's no sense of distinctiveness, first of all.
And then there's a lack of distinction between you and the world and between versions of yourself.
So if you're, if you're thinking of like a really basic version of like psychological
stability, reason and self-consciousness upends all of that.
And Hegel needs us to pass through that in order to, the thing is for me, like, I don't
really know what happens once you, like, I guess there's just this constant tension between
the two.
There's no like final.
Yeah.
I don't think there's ever, you never get through, right?
It's only ever the going or the, or it's like you get through this one only as this one over
here is erupting, right?
Because, you know, events over here triggered events over here.
I mean, you brought up Nietzsche.
It reminds me a bit, we talk about courage as well.
It reminds me that there's this, you can imagine a certain amount of dread in the transformations
between the camel to the, um, uh, the lion and then the lion to the child, right?
Like the camel has a, is, is content in sort of carrying the burdens, carrying the values
and the, the, the, the categories that define its life.
And there takes a courage and one is subjected to a certain amount of dread in attacking those
values, attacking those categories.
But that is still relatively speaking way safer than being subject to a force of like becoming
and, and, and, and, and the force of creation of, in the figure of the child.
Right.
It also makes me think of that, that sort of relationship between, um, reason and understanding
as, um, it reminds me of Deleuze's distinction between territorialization and de-territorialization
where the understanding is constantly literally like appropriatively territorializing things.
Whereas, uh, whereas reason is constantly taking those, the, the, the maps that have been created
and, and, and undoing them and, and, and, and prompting them to be reforged.
Right.
I think that's a, yeah, that's a good, uh, analogy as well.
Territorialization.
Cause yeah, the understanding attaches things and appropriates things.
So it's calcifying things and that's a source of comfort, right?
When we see objects and we can like orient ourselves in the world, we're comfortable and we're allowed
to just sort of be passive in a way.
Even when they're scary, right?
Like, I mean, this is the different, like, even if I can, if I can say, I hate you, you're
scary, you represent, I fear my life.
At least I, I know you, right?
Exactly.
I can, I can create that safe distance.
And de-territorialization, those are, those are a little hard to say.
Uh, that one is obviously, uh, you know, psychologically more discomforting, uncomfortable, uh, because
you're, there's not even a coherence of the self in that sense.
So you don't even, you're not even able to negotiate, you know, your own orientation, which
again, like it's productive for philosophy, de-territorialization.
It's sort of unproductive for basic engagement with the world.
Or, I mean, I don't know.
There's a, there's a weird tension there.
Well, it depends what you mean by basic.
I mean, like, I mean, this is where, this is, this is interesting.
I'm curious to see where it, um, the path that it takes us down is it seems that, you
know, even if reason were sort of subtracted from this equation and one were just, uh, working
with, with one's understanding, a calcification isn't, I don't, I can't imagine calcification
ever being complete.
Uh, it is a process of becoming its own because you know, the, the, the more you try to come,
this is where failure would actually, uh, uh, come to, um, come to play into the mix is
that the more you're trying to line up your categories and get them all to fit within the
big, you know, puzzle pictures that those, the, the boundaries of those, those categories
aren't going to fit.
Right.
And they're going to create friction and they're going to create imminently, you know, even
if a reason isn't some kind of external agent and comes up and fucks with it sort of like
as it's, as its purpose, you know, there's going to be a sort of natural, um, you know,
grinding of bone on bone tectonic shifts, you could call them.
Right.
As these categories are running into each other.
Yeah.
No, the process will upset itself kind of almost naturally it's or organically.
For Hegel, it seems like, but there is this sense that at least in his time and his time
period, that people are like desperately latching onto outdated forms of thinking that for Hegel
are disallowing some sort of progress.
I don't, I don't, I'm still like the character of that progress, the ethics involved in this
notion of progress.
I'm still very kind of, they're, they're, I don't know.
They're so ambiguous.
I don't know how to deal with the ingrained, uh, sort of telos here, even though we've,
as we've articulated, it seems not to be a humanist telos.
Uh, but it almost seems scarier, scarier without the human subject as the driver.
So it's like, I don't know how we're supposed to take Hegel's ethics.
If there is an actual ethics here, you know what I mean?
Like, and that's a larger question.
We don't necessarily have to deal with that, but it's, yeah, that's, I mean, I just take
it that, you know, if there's an ethics here, it's like act in such a way that advances spirit
without, you know, the advancement of spirit without knowing what that entails and just
know you're a, you're a means to an end.
Right.
Yeah.
It's just like, we have to do this.
That's not for the sake of the human.
Yeah.
No.
It's not even, yeah.
Like, who is it for?
There's no like.
It's like a spirit.
Yeah.
It's only the, the, the maturation of spirits that they're coming to this is the full coming
to be of spirit.
Yeah.
And that, I mean, the more you probe that, it's, it, I mean, maybe this is one of the
reasons why Hegel has been sort of abandoned by most progressive, like contemporary theory,
because that's such a confusing point.
Like why would we be serving something that's both us, part of us and kind of separable or
abstract?
Like, it just seems a little too deterministic for the, for modern contemporary theory, you
know?
Well, this is where he just seems so overtly religious, right?
Is that, you know, the human is nothing is, I mean, he, he complicates this because that,
you know, the typical line would be that the human is for the sake of the divine, right?
But here that line is blurred a bit because the human, human consciousness is the manifestation
of the divine, which means that that subject, the object boundary is, is permeated in some
ways.
So, I mean, it's, it is non-humanist in so far as there aren't human agents sort of realizing
their own ends, taking agency over themselves.
But the perpetual undoing and maturation of spirit is also the perpetual undoing and maturation
of human consciousness.
So you could also say there, there is a certain self-interestedness in here is like, this is
how we become the X-Men or whatever, right?
Right, right.
Yeah, you could definitely take it that way.
I mean, it's certainly, it's more Christian than it is like Buddhist, you know, for example.
I mean, there, there are these ties to Buddhism in the sense where he, you know, emphasizes the
void, right?
There's this void of consciousness and you could, I think the main distinction, I think Žižek
kind of brings this up is that for Buddhism, the void is the thing in itself.
So it's, it's actually separable from the human.
There's a nothingness that's just out there.
And for Hegel...
Well, that's a liberation into the void, is that not the liberation of suffering?
Right, but it's like a, it's, you have to basically abandon your subjectivity to reach
the asubjective void in Buddhism.
Whereas for Hegel, the void is the subject.
So there's no separability there.
It's like the, the actual mechanism of the concept of, of subjectivity is a void, is an
abyss.
So it's like the, it's not, Buddhism for Hegel is like, would be naive, I guess, right?
To think, to think that separability.
But it's still not, like, even though of course there's this, there's invocations of divinity
and he was like, you know, by all accounts, a good Lutheran, the text writes itself in
A way, right?
In that kind of Heideggerian sense, like the language starts speaking Hegel.
And I think you get a much more convoluted, ambivalent version of theism here that doesn't
allow for like the strict categories that you'd usually associate with it.
Well, to just begin with, the absolute is not absolute being, right?
Right.
I mean, that's, that, I mean, I mean, just think about how radical that claim is, that
that God, whatever it is, is not transcendent, fully formed, absolute, beyond us.
But in its absoluteness, its absoluteness is nothing, its absoluteness is nothing other
than the absolute unfolding or enfolding of, you know, of its movement, right?
That's, I mean, that's a, that's not a particularly humanist version of God.
No, no.
It's not even, it's not even sort of like, you know, the Enlightenment sort of like almost
mathematical understanding of God is just sort of like absolute truth.
Mm-hmm, right.
It's not the naive like notion of God as being.
I mean, even, we read in the, I think it was in the preface, yeah, later in the preface
where he, he kind of runs through the, the propositional logic and how it dissolves itself
when you try to match up that predicative, predicative logic, where if you have to say God
as being, then God is like already sublated and unraveled in that, in that conceptual process,
just acknowledging that it's like, well, then how do you get any kind of normal theism out
of this?
It's, it's, it's just like, how did he get a theism out of this when he had reached those
kinds of points?
You know what I mean?
Like, I think it's just a, I mean, I think what's happened is he deifies becoming.
Yeah.
Right?
And I don't think he can think becoming without a becoming toward.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And it doesn't matter what the toward the end is.
It can be anything, right?
It can be, you know, hooray or dread or annihilation or whatever else.
It's that if there's movement, it's got to be moving toward something.
And you can even understand it as an imminent movement toward, you know, think, again, think
Aristotelian, like, like, like Aristotle's movement is in many ways imminent.
It is the flourishing of, of the, the, the, the subject in question, right?
The full flourishing, it's not like an external movement along a path.
It is the full becoming of the organism, the flourishing, the eudaimonia, right?
Right.
Now that requires external ends for Aristotle, but they're, they're just accidentally attached
to the thing, right?
That, that kind of, it makes me think that the ethics is like, it's internal to the system.
And I, I think I've already kind of articulated that a little bit in my, in my project, but
I, I want to keep pressing on that because, I mean, ethics usually, it involves the, the,
the policy claim, which involves by extension, some version of choice, subjective choice.
We have to, or we must make these steps or decisions in order to foster a more ethical
world, better relations, you know, better versions of relations and politics in everyday life.
For Hegel, those, when he says we have to do this, I think he literally means we don't
have a choice.
Like, so it's not, it's not, it's not exactly a, we must claim in the sense of like, we,
or it's not a should claim.
It's a, we must, like, we literally have to do it.
There's no, there's no sense of choosing reason.
It's just going to happen.
You know?
Well, I mean, it's not deontological in that sense.
There isn't like a law that emerges that one has to, you know, satisfy.
Um, and it's not a consequentialism either because like one, like you, you know, precisely
because you, for Hegel, I don't think you can anticipate what that telos looks like.
So bringing it, bringing it about sort of like misses the point of having to inhabit it
here in the moment.
So, I mean, to just to think of the sort of the major, like, you know, branches of ethical
thought, you know, it's not consequentialism.
It's not deontological at all, but I do think it has an interesting resonance with virtue
theory, right?
Which is, I mean, if you took virtues as not, not as static, um, uh, qualities to express,
but as, as, um, styles of becoming, right?
I mean, like, what would it mean to be courageous in unfolding absolute spirit?
Right.
Mm-hmm.
No, yeah.
There, I mean, there definitely is.
I mean, I was sort of making a polemical claim there about like, there definitely are should
claims here as there are in Nietzsche where he's saying like, you know, we should foster
some version of the overman because there, there's cowardice in the other versions of the other
styles of being that come before that or that are like lesser than, than the overman, right?
I mean, the nobleman, the, and the camel or whatever, like those are, those are versions
of like coping with the complexity of reality.
Whereas, well, I think both for Hegel and for Nietzsche, we want a total immersion in that
complexity, you know, uh, regardless of the psychosocial consequences.
Well, I agree.
I mean, but like, think about the difference, the difference in kind of those should claims,
right?
That, you know, um, one's actions should be consistent, absolutely consistent with each
other, right?
That deal with like Kant's categorical imperative, um, versus, you know, we should act.
And so, so as to bring about the maximum amount of happiness, like those kinds of should
claims are, um, in relationship to some kind of universal, right?
Like whether or not it's, it's happiness or, or self-consistency, but what does it mean
to say you should be courageous in, uh, and, and you should not be cowardly in, you know,
in the enfolding of absolute spirit?
Well, that's only putting yourself in relationship to a style, like into a style of becoming.
So like the, at the propositional level, it doesn't hold in and of itself, right?
Yeah.
That's a different kind.
I agree.
That's a should claim, but it's a different kind of, I'm sure now I'm, I'm really heavily
leaning on this sort of mutated version of virtue theory, but it is an interesting place
to go.
Well, what is, who's does virtue theory or what does that come from?
Does that air?
Oh, well, like I've been contemporary with contemporary stuff or, I mean, like who are you, who are
you drawing from?
I've just never heard the term, I guess.
Oh, oh, well, it's, I mean, so it's a, it's a, um, contemporary thinkers tend to turn to
the Greeks, especially Aristotle.
Right.
I mean, the Nicomachean Ethics is sort of like a, um, uh, um, you know, a, an earth's place
for thinking virtues and think about the way the Nicomachean Ethics is just like nothing more
in some ways than like a toxic taxonomy of different virtues and finding the sort of relative medium
using the, the overarching virtue of practical wisdom or prudence as, as sort of like developing
the, as, as the, the means by which, um, uh, you know, the human becomes fully flourishing.
I mean, Alistair MacIntyre is, is a much more contemporary, has a much more contemporary take
on that.
And he actually takes Nietzsche as in some ways a virtue theorist in comparison to Aristotle.
Um, I don't, I, I, it's been so long since I've, I've read people who are explicitly identify
themselves as virtue theorists because I don't think they're all that.
Right.
It's not that hot.
Um, well, it is in certain circles, but I, I just never really bought their version of,
of, um, virtue theory, but I, I have those, those texts are in my office on campus.
So I can't tell you off the top of my head.
So you think...
Hurst House, Hurst House is one that I'm thinking of.
But are you, are you arguing that Hegel is putting forth kind of a, a weird version of
virtue theory or...
There's an interesting resonance there, right?
Because, you know, virtues are, um, I, I think of virtues as, um, as qualities of inhabitation,
right?
That one, um, um, becomes courageous by sort of inhabiting a sort of a courageous orientation
to, you know.
Yeah.
You know, you, you brought up faculty psychology earlier, and I think that, that kind of resonates
with virtue theory in a way, just in terms of the categorization of the, of the different
faculties.
And obviously Bacon also was sort of, uh, was really involved with that and with the idols
as well.
I think, I mean, I would claim at least provisionally that Hegel is doing something a little bit more
sophisticated just because, I mean, at least, at least from my, like, kind of, uh, my reading
of Žižek's version of Hegel, he lines up Hegel and Lacan so convincingly so that it's like
Hegel is almost a direct precursor of, of psychoanalysis.
And so there's not, there aren't exactly faculties for Lacan.
There's obviously tons of distinctions of like types of, and styles of, of being, but they're
not like, it's not as vulgar.
I'm, I'm not exactly sure how to make that, that differentiation.
You know what I mean?
Well, I, I mean, look, it seems pretty obvious to me that Hegel was inheriting a lexicon of
faculty psychology and he mobilizes it.
Now, I think he mobilizes it in some pretty funky ways that, as you say, are, are not nearly
as crude as Campbell or Bacon.
Um, you know, so I think that, uh, I mean, even Kant, um, and my, my sort of take on faculty
psychology is so thoroughly run through Deleuze's book on, on Kant that, you know, I have to, I
have to constantly sort of keep the, the, the, the two versions of the things in, in mind,
because I think there's a really dumb, reductive, crude version of faculty psychology.
And that's 99 out of a hundred of them.
And then it becomes much more interesting when I delusify it.
Of course.
Yeah.
And the same thing with ether.
I think ethos is usually a really clunky, clumsy idea, but it becomes much more interesting
when it gets destabilized.
Like when ethos isn't a being, but as a con is, as a, as a mechanism of becoming, um, so
I just, I just see little interesting resonances here between, um, you know, this is like, I
see faculty psychology when he's talking about the understanding and the reason and imagination
and, you know, things that typically get mobilized as faculties.
But I see some of that virtue theory stuff coming through when he's talking about dread
and courage and right, right, right.
Yeah.
No, I see that.
And they're not totally incompatible.
I think the main, I guess the main difference for me, and we've already, we've already kind
of covered this is the, the, they're not exactly separable, right?
There's no like absolute separation between the understanding and reason or between the understanding
and sense certainty, right?
They're all kind of culpable in one another and there's this irreducible sense of relationality
between each of those faculties, if you want to call them that.
So it's like that kind of, uh, that level of ambiguity there, I don't think was, I mean,
I don't know.
You could probably get that out of Bacon as well if you did some, if you did some massaging
of his conceptual system.
But for me, the emphasis on that culpability and ambiguity here makes it something, it makes
it a little different, uh, from like the crude version.
Yeah.
I agree.
I mean, but it's also interesting to take back that faculty psychology to Aristotle as
well, who, you know, in the Nicomachean ethics is laying out the intellectual virtues as, as
well.
Right.
And so the, the distinction between, you know, the, the, the intellectual virtues and the,
the, um, virtues of soul, uh, you know, the, the distinction between those are not nearly
as, um, like strident as they are with someone like Bacon.
And one of the things that I find the most interesting in, in dealing with Bacon, especially
when he's talking about faculty psychology and on the advancement of learning is, uh, this
is almost like an explication of the, the problem that Hegel's laying out is that as he's laying
down all of these, um, uh, categories, they are constantly running into each other and
he's constantly having to give all of these exceptions and caveats and, you know, it forces
him to constantly nuance it and you can almost see that territorialization, de-territorialization
activity in the process of him trying to taxonomize.
Yeah.
Right.
No, I remember that when I, cause I, I read a bunch of Bacon for a seminar paper, like a
few, like almost two years ago.
And I, I, that was exactly what I saw reading him.
It was like, you couldn't call him, you couldn't really call him like a proto-Hegelian or a proto-
deconstructionist, but the text was certainly deconstructing itself along the way because
he backs his way there.
He backs himself into these corners and he doesn't accept that that ambiguity is actually
constitutive.
He's constantly running away from it, but he is outlining it.
I mean, it's there.
It's just that.
Well, and it's his, it's his rigor and attention to detail that allows it to come to the fore,
like forefront.
He's not, he, he's never satisfied with the, he never has the contentness that understanding
is supposed to provide because his reason won't let it sit still.
Right.
I mean, it's, it's very similar to the way that Derrida, um, sort of applauds Austin's
exhaustive work at trying to categorize all the, you know, like the distinctions between
locutionary and illocutionary, you know, propositions.
He's like, look, he doesn't see how, he doesn't see the problem, but he's not willing to let it
rest either.
So he's constantly performing, you know, the deconstruction of, of these categorical distinctions.
Right.
That's why I think of Bacon as a pretty useful figure historically, because I mean, at least
to me and Foucault really briefly alludes to this in The Order of Things, but he name
drops Bacon as like a fulcrum sort of figure between the pre-classical version of knowledge
and knowledge production between that and then the classical or the enlightenment era.
So it's like, he wasn't, he, he identified a problem, right?
Which is that we can't, we can't like adequately observe or manipulate our reality, but he didn't,
as did Kant, identify that as basically unsurpassable.
So it's like there, he's, he, he occupies this weird space where he's like, because traditionally
he's, he's, when you look at like the, if there's like a diagonal line of progress in
knowing, Bacon's positioned right on that line as like a perfect step towards enlightenment
thinking.
But you can, you can think of it that way, but it's ironic because it's not as if it's
like this, this upward progress.
To me, at least if you're looking in this kind of Hegelian vein, he's like, he's, what's
the word?
He's like, he's, uh, he can't accept the, the implications of the problem that he outlines.
And that's what allows for progress.
It's not that he actually like gave us any real like scientific or technological or progress
in knowledge production.
It's that he ran up against the problem, couldn't accept the consequences, and that allowed for
Further outlining of those, that problem.